so somebody had asked me to make a video
comparing the potential with a power of
mutants versus Inhumans and imagine a
lot of this is just rooted in the fact
that we have x-men vs. and humans going
on right now the event I don't think is
slated to end for a little while but
those of you guys who are new to Marvel
Comics oh the guys who are not wildly
familiar with Marvel um the Inhumans of
the x-men are about as different as you
can get when it comes to what their role
is in the Marvel Universe when the
Inhumans first showed up and and
Fantastic Four number 45 in 1965 they
were just designed to be very small they
were designed to be very niche they were
never never huge they were only ever
maybe like 9 in humans and most said it
was he and human royal family and all
the stories really just focused on them
but the way that Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
made them they were designed to be
reclusive their origin story was rooted
in the Kree you know this alien race had
been fighting another race called the
scrolls and the Kree had come to the
realization that I think he basically
creates spies that could infiltrate
other civilizations they could conquer
those civilizations from within that's
what they did is they basically showed
up on earth they grabbed a handful of
humans they modify their genes and they
ensure that when these humans undergo
exposure to these gas to this gas called
the Terrigen mists that their cells
would be altered and they would take on
a new physical form now eventually the
Creed is kind of abandoned the
experiment and these Inhumans were just
sort of left in isolation and left to
govern themselves but they created a
very reclusive location called Attilan
and they just live there and so when
they first arrived the Fantastic Four
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby basically said
they had always been there we're just
now seeing them for the first time
because they're just now really stepping
out into the outside world but the
kicker with the Inhumans is that once
they underwent exposure to the Terrigen
mist there was no coming back I mean you
couldn't undo the Terrigen mists you
couldn't take that away you know
whatever physical form they took
whatever powers they developed they were
going to be that way for the rest of
their lives so for example in the in the
Inhumans community in a ton there's a
door there's a gateway that you can walk
through and it'll take you anywhere you
want to go in the world it's like Loch
Shaw the dog except that the door can't
go anywhere but that door was a person
at one point and after they underwent
terrigenesis they turn into a door that
allows people to go anywhere they want
to in the world it's a crazy situation
but that's just some of these
abilities that the inhumans developed
now having said that when the x-men
first showed up in x-men number one you
know in 1963 they were they were really
like an experiment because the Oh Marvel
was kind of messing around the idea of
saying hey let's create a teenage
superhero team and they were successful
for a little while I mean it worked
because you know at the time Marvel had
spider-man
so Spiderman was a teenage superhero
then they had the Fantastic Four they
had the Avengers which were you know
superhero teams and so the action was
like a best of both worlds it was a
teenage superhero team and it worked now
with their original introduction it was
really just the circumstance where he
was it was like you know there are these
people that he just stopped there that
have X genes and these X genes you know
will manifest under a multitude of
different conditions but the most
notable condition the most common
condition is puberty you know just like
hormones kick in around the time of
puberty this X gene would activate and
these kids would develop mutant powers
more often than not they wouldn't know
how to control them because their
families wouldn't even know that they
were mutants and so you would have you
know Charles Xavier you would have
Cyclops or somebody show up they would
appear to them tell them that they're
mutants that their powers
you know our gift and they would whisk
them off to the Xavier Institute where
they would just become part of the x-men
team learning how to use their abilities
the problem with this was that and
braven the bull number 50 for 1964 bc
turn right back around and created the
teen titans the teen titans were
basically children they were their
discomposed sidekicks you know from the
most notable DC superheroes at the time
not only that you had drama you had
romance you had teen angst eNOS I
meaning that you know all these these
really real-world teenage elements
thrown into the story the reason why
that blew the x-men out of the water was
because of the fact that teenagers liked
reading stories that were basically
about them where they could see
themselves in the stories and stuff ah
with Stan Lee and Jack Kirby they always
created their stories where unless it
was like Doctor Strange or unless it was
you know Ironman or stuff like that
Elissa serve some kind of political
purpose or drawing in some particular
group from you know beyond the United
States they were usually rooted in an
idyllic scenario what would it be like
if teenagers had powers you know and it
would be very out-there it'd be very fun
and be very enjoyable but you know we
were kind of encroaching on this age
where it was the rebel without a
and teenagers wanted to be rebels they
wanted to see themselves as rebels and
the Teen Titans let them do that but by
the time Chris Claremont took over the
x-men series up until that point the
Inhumans and the mmm and mutants were
kind of neck-and-neck in terms of
abilities because they were never fully
fleshed out I mean the writing of Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby the writing of work
Thomas you know the few other people who
came across before the x-men line was
cancelled they just focused on beasts
with agility
you know Cyclops adopted class Jean Grey
had you know telekinesis Iceman had ice
powers and you know Warren Worthington
had wings yeah you had the villain
magneto you had you know a handful of
mutants here and there who were
introduced with the Brotherhood if he
will even skull at which bridge silver
so on
but the power is Rivera contained they
were very minimal because there weren't
that many mutants out there just like
with the Inhumans there weren't that
many Inhumans out there so the powers
were very minimal but with Chris
Claremont took over this series he
didn't view the x-men as a superhero
team only he saw the x-men is potential
to basically create a soap opera he was
like let's focus on their individual
lives let's create new x-men let's
introduce new heroes let's create love
triangles let's have arguments let's
have debates let's have a circumstance
or several circumstances
we're not everyone agrees with Charles
Xavier 'zv you of a peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants let's let's
radically change Magneto and so because
of this we saw introductions of
characters like Nightcrawler Colossus
Wolverine I mean we saw all these
different powers being introduced now
you know we had people with
instantaneous healing factors people who
could teleport people who had an organic
metal skin you know and because of this
huge explosion under Chris Claremont for
the next 17 years he just kept adding
more and more mutants to it but he
couldn't have you know the same mutants
all with the same power they all had to
have unique powers and so sometimes
there were modifications Charles Xavier
was the telepath up until Emma Frost
showed up and then Emma Frost was the
telepath because she was more powerful
than Charles Xavier
you know we had guys like like sebastian
shaw we had you know people like bishop
you know both of them both of those guys
could absorb energy and then use it in
different ways sebastian shaw
turned it into physical strength bishop
just channeled it back at people we had
storm who could control the elements you
know it was really really cool
storytelling well the more mutants were
the more more towers were bolstered and
in fact there were some characters who
were wildly powerful you know as their
characters grew and as they progressed
for example
Franklin Richards was originally never
immune free cliff Richards was a kid
whose birth was engineered by way of the
cosmic control rod Sue Storm was
struggling with birth Reed Richards
Johnny Storm to think all thought she
was going to die so they went to the
negative zone they grabbed the cosmic
control rod of a nihilist which is
basically the negative zones equivalent
of the power cosmic they came back to
earth they helped Susan storm give birth
to Franklin Richards and then he was
basically imbued with a fraction of the
cosmic control rods power which is why
he was able to you don't turn himself
into an adult you know calling himself
avatar different things like that
but it's time progressed they basically
roll his character over to be or I guess
it was revealed to be a mutant this was
established in the onslaught saga that
was one of the biggest reasons why
Ocelot was so huge it's because Frankie
was no longer just some kid that could
do crazy things without any real
explanation it was well he's a mutant
with reality-warping powers because of
this mutants just grew to be more and
more powerful just because of the fact
that with so many mutants being added
all the time there had to be a way to
basically keep them more interesting and
so the powers became more and more
extreme but on the other side of the
coin the Inhumans were still small
it was so only maybe 9 or 10 in humans
they were just backup features in
Fantastic Four and Thor they had a few
volumes here and there like you know
Paul Qing is a J Lee's volume 2 which is
probably the best run ever but again it
was just a handful of Inhumans and you
know again you couldn't change the
powers of black hole you couldn't get
rid of his quasi hot ice cream that was
a result of terrigenesis and you can't
undo terrigenesis you know you can
change the powers of Medusa you can
change the powers of Oregon I guess you
could have added powers to Karnak but it
was really cool to have a guy who had no
powers Booker do you know who could
somehow since the structural weakness
and everything that he saw it was really
really cool the way their characters
were designed but they were always just
niche now all this changed over the
course of about 10 or 15 years when Joe
Quesada came onto the scene Joe Quesada
said hey look our comics are struggling
we got to trim the fat we got to get rid
of all these beetles I mean half when we
already been using and the other half
aren't even being used right so let's
just get rid of them you know let's
reduce them in number so we got the
House of M The Scarlet Witch Worth
reality so everybody had everything they
wanted
she's sent reality back to normal after
everybody confronted her about it and in
the last you know second she said no
more mutants and 98% of the mutants
population just became a giant ring you
know around the the planet Earth their
powers are basically gone and so you
know ninety-eight percent of Newton's
were now just regular people and it
really just kind of allowed Marvel to
start from scratch they reduced it down
to 198 there were several stories that
went on for a while we got decimation we
even got a line of stories called the
198 but the idea was to essentially
reduce them a number but even then 198
meetings were still a lot of mutants
that a lot of powers who were already
established but with the Inhumans it was
still just a small number it was just a
small number of adherents now again this
really changed with Marvel now the rumor
mills turned out a lot of things over
the course of the last you know three or
four years or so but Marvel now was like
a - a three-stage rollout it was a
progressive rollout that took place over
the course of you know some amount of
time and it was kind of like Marvel's
answer to DC's new 52 but instead of a
hard reboot Marvel has kind of shifted
things up a bit and they just more or
less switched creative teams they change
the position of some characters so Carol
Danvers was no longer Miss Marvel she
was now Captain Marvel there were a lot
of you know a few changes that were made
here in there but one of the major
changes that was made came out of an
event called infinity now this was
actually a - a - a two-face event so to
speak and the sense that on one half you
had the Avengers offer fighting things
and Hickel was basically retelling the
origin of the universe and on the other
hand you had Thanos invading the planet
Earth looking for his offspring during
the invasion of Earth he fought Black
Bolt of the Inhumans Black Bolt
detonated the Terrigen bomb and the
Terrigen mists started spreading
throughout the world that's why the
Terrigen mists are spreading through the
world right now and all-new
all-different marvel it's just a
continuation of the the Infinity
storyline going into inhuman and
inhumanity and all I kind of get stuff
but what this did is it allowed
different writers most notably Charles
Soule to come back and start expanding
the Inhumans roster more so than it had
ever seen before
instead of just the end humanly and
Attilan we now found out that with this
terrigen bomb blowing up and all these
different Inhumans coming into existence
it was like the space race there was a
mad dash to grab as many of these new
Inhumans as possible and we learned that
there were thousands of groups of
Inhumans that existed around the world
that no one ever knew about and with
this massive bolstering of
human population suddenly there were a
new plethora of inhuman powers were
cropping up that we hadn't seen before
now that we're in humans that could
absorb energy that were here in humans
that could discharge energy that were in
humans that could read minds it was all
crazy in terms of what their abilities
were but in terms of power by power
comparison the mutants come out on top
here just because of the fact that their
stories have been written much longer
there's a lot of news out there who
still existed are still wildly powerful
because when you think about it you've
got me in a second warp reality on a
cosmic scale
you've got mutants second good for the
minds of every being on the planet
you have mutants whose powers extend out
into the universe itself
you've got all different kinds of
beetles out there but within humans you
don't have in humans they could work
reality on a cosmic scale you don't have
in humans that could control the minds
of the world's populations and humans
powers are far more contained and humans
powers only have just large enough of a
sphere of influence that they can impact
the people in their immediate vicinity
but they can't really impact the whole
world but again this is hopefully this
answer the question that you guys have
but if you're new here two comments
explain I'll be sure to hit the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all at it please
[Music]